Andrea Liniger und ihre vier Kinder -
eine Familie von Homeschoolern.
Heute ist der Wald ihr Schulzimmer.
Hier sieht man: Viele Bäume
haben unterschiedliche Rinden.
Und wenn man
die Rinde genau betrachtet,
erkennt man daran die Bäume.
Siehst du,
der hat so eine Art Schuppen.
Und dann kann man hier nachsehen,
was das für ein Baum ist.
Wenn man mit der Lupe schaut,
sieht man sogar kleine Krabbeltiere.
Ja. Hier und überall.
Ja, das ist Biologie
in ihrer Reinform.
Denn es ist nicht nur theoretisch,
sondern ganz natürlich.
Es wird am eigenen Körper erlebt.
Aber die Kinder sind eigentlich
noch viel zu klein dafür.
Ja, aber sie interessieren sich
für ihre Umwelt,
die Natur und die ganzen Abläufe.
Ich esse die Buchstaben.
- Gut.
Amanda und Bastian
gehen seit eineinhalb Jahren
nicht mehr zur Schule.
Ihre kleinen Brüder Elia und Lionel
werden vielleicht nie
ein Klassenzimmer von innen sehen.
Das ist der Igel.
- Der Igel.
Die Spuren der Tiere
sind jetzt etwas verdeckt,
wegen des vielen Laubs am Boden.
Dadurch sieht man sie nicht so gut.
Hier im Wald, in der Natur
lernen sie viel fürs Leben,
damit sie sich in dieser Welt
zurechtfinden.
So friert das ...
- Nein, das friert nicht.
Sie sehen, wovon sie umgeben sind,
sie verbinden sich mit der Natur,
werden dadurch auch sehr achtsam,
was mir sehr wichtig ist.
Sie sollen lernen,
sorgsam mit der Natur umzugehen
und dass man die Ressourcen
schützen muss.
Ich erlebe es so,
dass sie ganz viel lernen.
* Sanfte, perlende Melodie *
Es muss uns bewusst sein:
Wenn wir das Spiel des Kindes
unterbrechen, ist das Gewalt.
Wenn wir das Kind davon zu über-
zeugen versuchen, etwas zu lernen,
mit welchem Vorwand auch immer,
wie schön wir es auch einpacken,
wenn wir ein Kind dazu bringen,
etwas zu lernen,
was es nicht interessiert
oder gerade nicht lernen möchte,
ist das Gewalt.
* Sanfte Melodie *
In diesem Film
kommen Menschen zu Wort,
die nie in eine Schule gegangen sind
oder die der Volksschule
den Rücken zugekehrt haben.
Trotzdem lernen sie viel und gern.
Oder vielleicht gerade deswegen?
Ich konnte es schon. In der
Berufsschule hatten wir auch Mathe.
Damit hatte ich kein Problem,
weil ich den Sinn dahinter sah.
Aber solange ich
keinen Sinn dahinter sehe -
Dreisätze, wozu löst man die?
Ich kann Noten
einfach nicht ... ganz ernst nehmen.
Für mich zeigen sie nur,
wie gut ich etwas lernen
und dann abliefern kann,
so, wie jemand das will.
Ich frage mich, wie das ist,
wenn Kinder
quasi während ihrer ganzen Kindheit
bewertet und verglichen werden.
Was macht das mit ihnen?
Ah, gut, das ist gerade ein L,
dann nehme ich L-A.
L-A ...
- Leo, was ist das?
I wie Igel.
- Ja, super.
Gagi.
* Fröhliche, treibende Melodie *
Was steht denn hier
über die Landwirtschaft?
Das sind die schädlichsten Gase.
Die machen die Ozonlöcher.
Das ist cool.
Findest du, so ist es fertig?
Ja.
Homeschooling bei Familie Liniger
im bernischen Worb.
Im oberen Stock
des alten Bauernhauses
bereitet sich der 14-jährige Bastian
auf die Aufnahmeprüfungen
für die Mittelschule vor.
Zuvor besuchte Bastian
die Mittelstufe einer Steinerschule.
Dort fühlte er sich wohl,
hatte Freunde,
seine Leistungen überzeugten.
Trotzdem:
Er hatte z.T. den ganzen Tag
Unterricht, kam dann nach Hause
und ist dann fast zusammengebrochen.
Er weinte und mochte nicht essen.
Er sagte, er wisse nicht, warum.
Er wisse nicht, was mit ihm los sei.
Er fragte,
ob wir Ärzte aufsuchen könnten,
die ihm sagen, was mit ihm los ist.
Und, ähm ...
Ich hatte das nicht in erster Linie
auf die Schule abgewälzt
oder das Gefühl,
die Schule sei der Grund.
Dann kamen lange Sommerferien
und ich merkte,
dass er schon nach kurzer Zeit
aufblühte.
Plötzlich sah ich wieder mein Kind.
Ich sah seine Interessen. Er begann
zu kochen, Projekte zu starten.
Er hatte ganz viele Ideen, reiste
umher, um sich Dinge anzusehen.
Jetzt sprudelt er wieder.
Ich habe mir selber
einen Stundenplan gemacht:
D/M ist Deutsch oder Mathe,
je nachdem, was ich gerade lerne.
Im Moment ist es Mathematik.
Das ist NMM: Natur, Mensch, Mitwelt.
Das ... ist alles Mögliche -
Geschichte, Bio, Physik ...
Woran arbeitest du da gerade?
Im Moment befasse ich mich
gerade mit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Ich gehe oft in Bibliotheken
und auch zu Leuten.
Gerade hier in der Nachbarschaft
gibt es viele,
die in Informatik, Mathematik
oder Deutsch sehr stark sind
und auch einen Beruf
in dieser Richtung ausüben.
Aber auch über das Internet.
Ja.
Mir gefällt, dass mir meine Mutter
nicht sagt, was ich jetzt tun muss,
sondern dass ich das machen darf,
was mir auch Freude bereitet.
Was bereitet dir denn
am meisten Freude?
Ich rechne gerne.
Oder ...
Ja, oder solche Sachen basteln.
Deutsch und Französisch
mag ich nicht so sehr.
Aber das lernst du dann trotzdem?
- Ja, ja.
Sagt dir deine Mutter, du sollst,
oder denkst du selber, dass du musst?
Ich merke selber, dass ich einfach
mal wieder Deutsch machen muss.
Und dann mache ich das halt, auch
wenn ich es nicht so gerne tue.
Die 13-jährige Amanda würde heute
die siebte Klasse besuchen.
Ihr kleiner Bruder Lionel
wäre im zweiten Kindergarten,
würde er nicht zu Hause lernen.
Du musst herausfinden,
welches die grösste Zahl ist.
Als wir
mit dem Homeschooling begannen,
war es während der ersten zwei
Monate für sie auch anstrengend,
habe ich das Gefühl.
Dieser Wechsel von einer Lehrperson,
die einem immer sagt,
was man zu tun hat
und wie es richtig bzw. falsch ist,
ähm ...
... dazu, dass da plötzlich
ein Gegenüber ist,
das mich unterstützt und begleitet,
mir aber nicht sagt,
wie ich es genau machen soll.
Oder was ich genau machen soll.
Das war anfangs schwierig für sie.
Sie sagten:
"Du bist doch jetzt meine Lehrerin,
du musst mir sagen,
was ich machen soll."
Da mussten wir etwas durchhalten.
Beide Seiten.
Und auch von meiner Seite
war viel Vertrauen nötig,
damit ich nicht aufgab und fand,
ich könne nicht Mutter
und Lehrerin sein.
Ich merkte, dass ich
gar keine Lehrerin zu sein brauchte.
Ich begleite sie in ihrem Lernen.
K-R-O-A-T-I-E-N.
Kroat...
Kroatien!
- Ja!
Andrea Linigers Kinder sind zwar
sehr frei in dem, was sie lernen.
Doch auch sie befolgen die Vorgaben
des kantonalen Lehrplans.
Wenn wir den Lehrplan anschauen,
merken wir,
dass vieles
schon automatisch passiert ist.
Sie kamen auf irgendeinem Weg,
über irgendein Thema
sowieso schon dorthin.
Wenn etwas offenbleibt,
gebe ich auch mal einen Input.
Ich schlage vor,
dass wir das zusammen anschauen.
Oder ich gebe ihnen ein Lehrmittel,
drucke Arbeitsblätter aus.
Die Vorteile sind,
dass die Kinder ganz ohne Angst
und mit viel Motivation lernen.
Dass sie so lange
an etwas dran bleiben,
wie sie mögen
und es auch aufnehmen können.
D.h., sie lernen so sehr nachhaltig.
Und wir haben die Möglichkeit,
rauszugehen, wenn es gerade passt,
um zu forschen und zu entdecken.
* Lachen *
Mami, runter!
Bastians Leidenschaft ist das Kochen.
Da kommt das Sushi angefahren und
man kann sich eine Schale nehmen.
Dafür darf er sich Zeit nehmen.
Kochen ist in dieser Familie
nicht weniger wichtig
als Mathe, Deutsch oder Französisch.
Nützlich ... unnütz - ich finde das
allgemein schwierig zu trennen.
Es ist ja auch schwierig zu wissen,
wie man sich einst entwickelt,
wo jemand nötig sein wird, welches
Wissen man sich aneignen muss,
um dann dort erfolgreich sein
zu können, wo man das will.
Darum ist es noch schwierig
zu beurteilen,
was nützlich und was unnütz ist.
Homeschooling wird oft ultra-
religiösen Kreisen zugeschrieben.
Bei keiner
der hier porträtierten Familien
gab aber ihr Glaube
den Ausschlag für diesen Bildungsweg.
* Sanfte Klaviermelodie *
* Die Melodie bricht ab. *
Dieses Intervall
kann man mit zwei und fünf greifen.
So ist es wahrscheinlich einfacher.
Du kannst mal versuchen, ob dir
das mit dem zweiten auch liegt.
Also, zwei und fünf.
Ja, genau.
Ja.
Das Entscheidende ist, dass sie
macht, was sie interessiert.
Das ist nicht nur das,
worauf sie Lust hat.
Es ist vielleicht mit etwas
Positivem verbunden, sie will es,
etwas, worauf sie Lust hat, ja.
Aber sie entwickelt
auch eine Motivation,
dafür zu arbeiten, etwas zu leisten.
Das ist der grosse Unterschied.
Es ist nicht,
wie einen Lolli zu lutschen.
Das merke ich bei ihr auch:
Sie kommt hierher, weil sie will.
Darum ist sie auch bereit,
etwas zu leisten.
Vielleicht hat sie dadurch
sogar die besseren Voraussetzungen,
durchzubeissen, wenn es darum geht,
die Tonleitern zu spielen.
Denn sie weiss, warum sie es tut.
Sie tut es nicht für andere,
sondern für sich selber,
weil sie das lernen will.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmelodie *
Man sagt dann gerne: "Der hat das
autodidaktisch gelernt."
Aber in "Autodidakt"
höre ich so eine Einsamkeit.
Und lernen kann man nicht alleine.
Man lernt nur,
weil es die anderen gibt.
Ohne die anderen
würde man überhaupt nicht lernen.
Man würde überhaupt nichts lernen.
Also eben:
ohne Unterricht, aber nicht alleine.
Andre Stern ist Freilerner.
Er sagt von sich,
er sei ein spielendes Kind geblieben,
weil niemand
ihn in seinem Spiel gestört habe.
Stern ist Gitarrist, Gitarrenbauer,
Journalist, Theaterschaffender
und Autor.
Einen Abschluss
machte er in keinem dieser Berufe.
Die meisten Menschen
üben einen Beruf aus,
für den sie nicht ausgebildet sind.
Die Menschen, die wir
in unserer Gesellschaft bewundern,
von Einstein bis Steve Jobs,
sind eigentlich Schulabbrecher
und haben somit
keine Qualifikationen.
Dafür haben sie eine hohe Kompetenz.
Das sehen wir
in unserem beruflichen Alltag auch.
Die grossen Firmen und Konzerne,
z.B. in Amerika, beginnen zu sagen:
"Wir wollen keine Diplome mehr,
wir sehen die gar nicht mehr an."
"Denn sie sagen nichts darüber aus,
was der Mensch alles kann."
"Die Qualitäten,
die uns interessieren -
Kreativität, Ausdauer, Fähigkeit,
über sich hinauszuwachsen usw. -
für die gibt es
weder ein Fach noch ein Diplom."
Und diese Qualitäten,
die die grossen Unternehmer
bei ihren Mitarbeitern
so gerne hätten,
sind solche, die wir
bei einem spielenden Kind finden.
Tiefe, Konzentration, Ausdauer,
die Fähigkeit,
über sich hinauszuwachsen.
Kinder tun im Spiel Dinge,
die sie nicht machen würden,
wenn wir das von ihnen verlangten.
All diese Qualitäten,
die wir unterbrechen,
um das Kind auf diese Qualitäten
vorzubereiten.
Für mich, der das von aussen be-
trachtet, ist das besonders absurd.
Mir geht es nicht darum, dass wir
alle verspielte Kinder sein sollen,
sondern dass wir das spielende Kind
ernst nehmen.
Was er damit meint, zeigt Stern
am Beispiel seines Sohnes Antonin.
* Klassische Musik *
Das Kind spielt nicht.
Das ist sein Spiel.
Bis in die letzten Fasern
seines Wesens.
Und diese Tiefe,
diese Ernsthaftigkeit
sollten wir als Erwachsene
eigentlich auch haben.
* Dramatischer Schluss
eines klassischen Stücks *
Wenn man dem Kind sagt:
"Du musst jetzt aufhören zu spielen
und zu lernen beginnen", kann
das Kind das unmöglich verstehen.
Genauso wenig, wie wenn ich
von Ihnen verlangte zu atmen,
ohne Luft zu holen.
Das Kind stellt den Erwachsenen
dann aber nicht infrage,
denkt nicht,
der Erwachsene habe ein Problem,
sondern es selber habe ein Problem.
Sobald das Kind dazu gebracht wird -
das sah man in der Hirnforschung -
werden im Hirn
dieselben Netzwerke aktiviert
wie bei körperlichen Schmerzen.
Das bedeutet für das Kind
noch etwas Schwerwiegenderes.
Nämlich: "Du bist dein Spiel."
"Ich halte dein Spiel
für nicht ernst."
"Ich halte dein Spiel für nichtig,
also kann ich es unterbrechen."
"Also halte ich dich für nichtig."
Und ... das verletzt das Kind.
Und das bleibt für immer.
* Sanfte Flamenco-Melodie *
Andre Stern
ist in Frankreich aufgewachsen
und hat keinen einzigen Tag
in der Schule verbracht.
Anders als beim Homeschooling
unterrichteten ihn seine Eltern nie.
Sie verschafften ihrem Sohn lediglich
Materialien und Kontakte zu Menschen,
die seinen Wissensdurst
stillen konnten.
Sie entschieden sich
nicht  g e g e n  die Schule.
Sie hatten sehr gute Erfahrungen
damit gemacht, waren gute Schüler.
Sie rechneten also
nicht mit der Schule ab.
Ihre Motivation
war eher ihre tiefe Überzeugung,
dass Kinder
perfekt ausgestattet zur Welt kommen
und dass sie,
abgesehen vom sicheren Hafen,
von uns keine Inputs brauchen,
keine Massnahmen, keine Erziehung.
Und da muss man
eine Reihe Entscheidungen treffen.
Eine davon war, dass wir nicht
in die Schule geschickt wurden.
Aber wir hätten jederzeit zur Schule
gehen können, hätten wir gewollt.
Ich kenne auch viele Kinder, die
in der Schule geschnuppert haben.
Und fast alle
gaben dasselbe Feedback:
"Es ist sehr spannend -
wenn ich mehr Zeit hätte,
würde ich öfters hingehen."
Heute Morgen müssen wir
diesen Baum hier schneiden.
Dabei müssen wir die Form beachten.
Ja, sehr gut.
- Super.
David Widmer,
einst ein traumatisierter Schüler,
heute gelernter Landschaftsgärtner.
An der Schule
war das Fenster das Interessanteste,
weil man dadurch die Natur sah.
Das kam ziemlich unmotiviert rüber.
Sie litten also in der Schule?
- Ja, in diesem Fall schon.
Es ist nicht so,
dass ich es nicht gekonnt hätte.
In der Berufsschule hatte ich
einen 5,5-Durchschnitt.
Daran lag es nicht. Aber ich hatte
absolut keine Lust an der Schule.
David war die letzten zwei Jahre
seiner obligatorischen Schulzeit
Homeschooler.
Mein Traum war es immer,
in der Natur arbeiten zu können.
Mir war der naturnahe Gartenbau
wichtig: kein Gift oder Beton.
Ich wollte beim Ursprünglichen,
Natürlichen bleiben.
Ich schrieb eine Bewerbung und
bekam meine absolute Traumstelle.
In Daniel Mosimann
fand David einen Lehrmeister,
der dem eigenen Urteil mehr vertraute
als einem Schulzeugnis.
Ich sagte ihm,
er solle mal arbeiten kommen.
Und da sah ich seine Leidenschaft,
seinen Einsatz.
Ich sah, dass er lernen will.
Ich fand,
er habe eine Chance verdient.
Ich musste ihm
nie gross klarmachen,
was er noch alles lernen sollte.
Er kümmerte sich selber darum. Das
war für mich auch eine Entlastung.
Haben Sie das Gefühl, das habe auch
etwas mit Homeschooling zu tun
oder ist das einfach sein Wesen?
Es ist wohl beides:
auf der einen Seite seine Art,
dass er genau
über Dinge Bescheid wissen will,
die ihn interessieren,
auf der anderen Seite
mussten sie dort auch selber
den Themen nachgehen
und wurden
zur Selbstständigkeit erzogen.
Das merkte man schon.
Ich erkannte
den Zusammenhang wieder.
Z.B. die Berechnung einer Fläche
oder des Kiesbedarfs,
um ein Objekt zu erstellen.
So ergab das Ganze einfach Sinn.
Das ist eine Trockenmauer,
eines der Spezialgebiete
des naturnahen Gartenbaus,
mein Abschlussprojekt.
Ich erhielt eine 5,8 für die LAP.
Ich war sehr zufrieden.
Da sind keine Bindemittel,
und Pflanzen wachsen darin.
Es ist sehr nahe an der Natur.
Franziska Widmer, Davids Mutter.
Als David 14 war, entschieden sie
und ihr Mann sich fürs Homeschooling.
Heute unterrichtet sie noch Davids
jüngsten Bruder Josha zu Hause.
Super, schon fertig. Wunderbar.
Ich lese es noch kurz durch.
Wenn das Wort etwas mit Ende zu tun
hat, schreibst du es mit einem D
und sonst mit einem T.
Jetzt kannst du einfach
weiterfahren. Das machst du gut.
Warum sprechen Sie hochdeutsch?
Wir haben ja
eine Schulsituation zu Hause.
In der Schule
sprechen sie auch hochdeutsch.
Gerade bei Deutsch und Mathe
gebe ich mir Mühe.
Es ist auch etwas einfacher:
Die Hauptfächer haben wir am Morgen.
Wenn ich hochdeutsch spreche,
ist es für Josha -
und früher
auch für die anderen beiden - klar,
dass die Mutter jetzt
der Homeschool-Teacher ist.
Das sind Schneckenbuntbarsche
aus dem Tanganjikasee.
Das kann man
ethisch gut verantworten.
Auch in der Natur haben sie
einen Raum von ca. 20 auf 20 cm.
Ich mag es nicht, wenn ein Fisch
immer der Scheibe entlangschwimmt.
Sie fühlten sich in der Schule
wohl wie ein Fisch,
der der Scheibe entlangschwimmt.
Das kann man so sagen:
Wie ein Fisch, der immer raussah,
jedoch selber immer
der Scheibe entlangschwamm.
Er konnte drinnen nicht mitspielen.
Er hatte die Freude am Leben verlo-
ren, war lust- und motivationslos.
Das zu sehen,
schmerzte mich als Mutter.
Ich hatte eine Freundin,
die Homeschooling machte.
Sie war aber Lehrerin.
Sie fragte mich, ob ich das
nicht auch machen wolle bei David.
Ich meinte, sie als Lehrerin könne
das, aber ich sei doch Kauffrau.
Aber den Gedanken hatten wir dann
während drei, vier Jahren in uns.
Irgendwann sprachen wir dann
mit einem Schulleiter.
Er sagte uns,
er habe nicht das Gefühl,
David könnte eine normale Lehre
absolvieren.
Eher eine Attestlehre,
wenn überhaupt.
Da erschraken wir schon etwas
und dachten:
"Okay, ups! Dann haben wir
ja nichts mehr zu verlieren,
wenn wir das Kind
aus der Schule nehmen."
Auch Widmers leben im Kanton Bern.
Dieser pflegt einen liberalen Umgang
mit dem sog. privaten Unterricht.
Schau, an der Wassertonne siehst du,
was wir heute Morgen lernten.
1 m hoch, 1 m breit, 1 m lang -
ungefähr.
Wie viel ist hier drin?
- 1'000 l.
Genau. Wie viele Kilos sind das?
1 t oder 1'000 kg.
- Mhm, genau. Super. Tipptopp.
Mit David versuchten wir,
die Schule in unsere Schulstube
hineinzukopieren.
Gerade bei Mathe merkte ich,
dass mich das extrem stresste.
Denn ich merkte,
dass es nicht so ankommt.
Wie muss ich jetzt das ...
Erst mit der Zeit merkte ich,
dass ich es lockerer nehmen kann.
Wir konnten Dinge wägen oder messen,
es musste nicht
stur nach Schulbuch laufen.
Sondern das Schulbuch
ist mein Leitfaden.
Es zeigt mir den Lehrplan,
die Stossrichtung.
Aber die Art und Weise,
wie ich es vermittle,
ist mir selber überlassen.
Und dann ...
stiegen wir aufs Fahrrad.
Auf dem Radweg
von Münsingen nach Wichtrach
fuhren wir nebeneinander hin und her
und übten das Einmaleins.
Das machte Spass,
denn er konnte sich bewegen.
Und in Bewegung lernt man leichter.
Er ist sowieso bewegungsfreudig.
So lernte er das Einmaleins
auf dem Fahrrad.
Für mich war es wie die Hoffnung
auf einen Neuanfang.
Ich dachte, jetzt ... Ich war
extrem motiviert, mitzumachen.
Viele fragten mich,
wie ich das machen würde,
sie würden nie
auf ihre Mutter hören,
die hätte ihnen nichts zu sagen.
Ich erklärte, man müsse jede Chance
wie einen Neuanfang sehen.
Man muss die Chance nutzen und
sehen, was man daraus machen kann.
Ich fand,
unsere Beziehung wurde schöner.
Entspannter jedenfalls.
Denn davor hatten wir so viel ...
... mit Elterngesprächen
und diesem und jenem.
Wir sollten mehr Aufgaben machen,
sie wollten aber nicht mehr,
wenn sie zu Hause waren.
Dieses abendliche Aufgabentheater
belastete die Beziehung
mit den Jungs wahnsinnig
und vergiftete auch
das ganze Familienklima.
Est-ce que tu veux sortir une tasse
et une soucoupe, s'il te plait?
Une tasse et ...
Homeschooling ist bei Familie Widmer
generationenübergreifend.
Die zweisprachige Grossmutter
unterrichtet Französisch,
der Grossvater
das Fach Natur, Mensch, Mitwelt.
Als er bei uns war,
ist David förmlich explodiert
in Bezug auf das Lernen.
Das hat nicht einfach
mit unseren Fähigkeiten zu tun,
sondern ich denke, uns gelang es,
den nötigen Raum zu schaffen,
in dem er sich entwickeln konnte.
Aber das Potenzial war in ihm.
Schau, ich zeige dir,
wie ich es vorbereitet habe.
Hier habe ich eine Nut rausgefräst.
Vater Christoph Widmer, gelernter
Maler, arbeitet heute als Pfleger.
Er unterrichtete seine drei Söhne
im Fach Werken.
Sohn Lukas ist in seinem
letzten Lehrjahr als Schreiner.
Früher haben wir im Bastelraum
verschiedene Sachen angeschaut.
Ich bin halt eher der Allrounder und
weiss über gewisse Dinge Bescheid,
die ich den Kindern
beibringen konnte.
Jetzt ist Lukas auf dem
Schreinerberuf natürlich ein Profi.
Jetzt sagt er, wie es geht,
und ich unterstütze ihn,
reiche ihm das Material.
Es gab eine Art Rollentausch.
Aber das finde ich gut.
Auch Lukas hat seine Lehrstelle
ohne ein Abschlusszeugnis gefunden.
Dort, wo ich die Lehre gemacht habe,
in der Lädere,
machten sie einen Eignungstest.
Da überprüften sie,
ob ich die Voraussetzungen
in Praxis und Theorie erfülle.
Auch in den Schreinereien,
in denen ich war,
hatten sie meist eigene Prüfungen.
Es war also kein grosses Problem,
kein Zeugnis zu haben.
Vater Christoph Widmer
arbeitet in einem Altersheim.
Damit seine Frau sich ganz
aufs Unterrichten konzentrieren kann,
muss sein Gehalt
als Familieneinkommen ausreichen.
Man muss sich
einfach sehr einschränken.
Wir haben z.B. seit zehn Jahren kein
Auto mehr, machen keine Ferien.
Dafür machen wir Ausflüge. Z.T. mit
Homeschoolern, z.T. auch einfach so.
Aber sich finanziell einzuschränken,
bedeutet nicht,
dass man weniger glücklich ist.
Wenn ich ehrlich bin:
Als wir noch in einer Blockwohnung
in Münsingen wohnten
und alle Leute
Karten aus den Ferien schickten,
wir aber nicht gingen,
war das schon manchmal hart.
Aber die Investition
hat sich für Sie gelohnt?
Auf jeden Fall, ja.
Ich würde es wieder gleich machen.
402 Homeschooler
leben im Kanton Bern.
Marianne Fankhauser
ist Schulinspektorin.
Einmal im Jahr besucht sie
die 15 Homeschooler-Familien
ihres Schulkreises.
Gerne hätten wir sie
bei einem solchen Besuch begleitet,
doch keine Familie liess sich
für dieses Filmprojekt gewinnen.
Homeschooler scheuen die Medien.
Die wenigsten
möchten sich exponieren.
Darum erzählt Schulinspektorin
Fankhauser in ihrem Büro,
worauf sie und ihre Kollegen achten.
Hauptkriterium: die Einhaltung
der kantonalen Lehrpläne.
Ich bin wieder da.
Wir Inspektorinnen und Inspektoren
kennen den Lehrplan sehr gut
und können schnell abschätzen,
ob jemand auf Kurs ist oder nicht.
Andererseits ist der Lehrplan
ja kein Gesetzbuch.
Unser Erziehungsdirektor
Bernhard Pulver
sagt im Zusammenhang mit dem Lehr-
plan 21 immer, er sei ein Kompass.
Er ist also kein Gesetzbuch.
Er ist richtungsweisend,
er gibt die Inhalte,
wir nennen sie Stufenziele, vor.
Damit man die Garantie hat:
Wenn man diese erreicht,
an ihnen gearbeitet hat,
dann kann die nächste Stufe
angepackt werden.
Die Lehrpläne
geben Lernziele für zwei Jahre vor.
Auch Homeschooler
sind frei darin zu entscheiden,
wann sie welche Schwerpunkte setzen.
Doch Lerninhalte sind nur das eine.
Die Schule bietet halt extrem viel
zur Thematik miteinander leben,
einander respektieren.
Sie müssen lernen,
sich in eine Klasse einzuordnen.
Sie lernen viele Meinungen kennen,
merken: "Aha, es gibt
noch viele weitere Familien."
Das erlebt man sonst nicht,
diese Vielfalt,
die unsere Gesellschaft ausmacht.
Dem wird in der Schule
Rechnung getragen.
Ich denke, dass es im Homeschooling
auch vielfältige Möglichkeiten gibt,
soziale Kontakte zu schaffen.
Man muss die sozialen Kontakte
vielleicht manchmal suchen,
das Kind bei der Suche unterstützen.
Aber die sind durchaus gegeben.
Lustig ist auch: Aussenstehende,
v.a. die Öffentlichkeit, Politiker
legen viel Wert darauf,
ohne zu sehen, dass
dieselbe Situation in der Schule
auch viel Negatives mit sich bringt.
Z.B. im Bereich Mobbing.
Was auf Pausenplätzen
oder Schulwegen abgeht.
Das sind
herausfordernde Situationen,
die man in einer Gruppe
erleben kann.
Das wissen wir alle auch
in der Gesellschaft.
Auf der anderen Seite gehören sie
dazu. Auch da lernen wir viel.
Wichtig ist ja immer, dass die
Kinder in schwierigen Situationen
gute Netze, Familien haben,
die sie stärken
und tragfähige Beziehungen erleben.
So können sie
auch die Erfahrung machen,
dass das nicht immer
nur die Familie ist.
Das ist auch wieder ein Gewinn,
in dem Sinne.
Es ist zwar tragisch,
so etwas zu erleben.
Aber das andere
ist auch sehr wertvoll.
Fehlende Sozialkontakte
und Sozialkompetenzen
sind die am häufigsten geäusserten
Kritikpunkte am Homeschooling.
Jedes Kind hat das Bedürfnis,
rauszugehen und etwas
mit jemandem zu unternehmen.
Ich kenne niemanden,
der nur zu Hause sitzt oder so.
Gut, es gibt sicher solche,
die nur gamen.
Dann muss man das halt fördern,
aber das ist nicht unüberwindbar.
Das war für uns nie ein Thema.
Klar, man muss z.T. mehr
Eigeninitiative ergreifen und sagen:
"So, ich gehe jetzt raus
und spiele mit anderen."
"Ich suche Kontakte,
trete Sportvereinen bei."
Wir waren in mehreren.
Dort macht man mit
und gibt sein Bestes.
Und wenn sie sehen,
dass man gute Leistungen bringt,
ist man sofort dabei.
Dann sind die Umstände nicht so:
"Der ist Homeschooler,
mit dem will ich nicht spielen."
Das gibt es unter Kindern nicht.
Diesen Unterschied
machen v.a. Erwachsene.
Einen Punkt
sehe ich auch immer öfter:
Diesen Kindern oder nachher auch
Jugendlichen fehlt die Privatsphäre.
Sie sind zu Hause,
alle wissen alles,
die Eltern sind involviert,
wissen, was läuft, was geht.
Aber wenn ich in die Schule gehe,
habe ich auch die Möglichkeit
auf ein Privatleben,
mit meinen Freunden
zu reden, worüber ich will.
Auch einmal etwas ausprobieren,
wovon ich weiss,
dass es nicht so gut ist.
Da sehe ich in der Schule
einfach einen Pluspunkt.
Ich würde meine Kinder
nie privat schulen.
Ich denke, es ist wichtig,
dass die Kinder Teil
eines sozialen Netzwerkes werden.
Dass sie lernen,
Rücksicht zu nehmen,
andere Meinungen zu hören
und zu respektieren.
Dass sie streiten lernen
und im Frieden zu diskutieren,
denn das ist die Basis
unseres Staates.
Auf der anderen Seite bin ich
manchmal auch froh um dieses Ventil,
wenn eine Volksschule oder
eine Regelklasse entlastet wird,
wenn es wirklich nicht geht.
Und ich respektiere
den riesigen Einsatz,
den die Eltern z.T. leisten. Hut ab!
Ich muss sagen, ich hätte mir
das nie vorstellen können,
insbesondere auf Sekundarstufe I,
die anspruchsvollen Inhalte
den Kindern weiterzugeben.
* Sanfte Flamenco-Gitarrenmelodie *
Andeer im Kanton Graubünden.
Im Atelier von Gitarrenbaumeister
Werner Schär
klopfte vor über 20 Jahren
ein Vater mit seinem Sohn an
und fragte
nach ganz besonderen Saiten.
Es waren Andre Stern
und sein Vater Arno.
Sie waren sehr beeindruckend.
Beide, auch der Vater.
Sie erschienen mir
wie von einem anderen Planeten.
Ich bemerkte seine Begeisterung
für dieses Instrument.
Sie erinnerte mich
an meine eigene Begeisterung.
Ist das jetzt Arbeit, Freizeit,
Spielen oder Lernen für Sie?
Ich kann bis heute nicht zwischen
diesen Begriffen unterscheiden.
Denn das ist sehr ernsthafte Arbeit.
Sie verzeiht
keine Sekunde Unkonzentriertheit.
Das ist eben
der Zustand des Spielens.
Das spielende Kind
ist so hoch konzentriert,
dass man es
fast nicht ansprechen kann.
Obwohl Stern noch nie auf irgendeinem
Gebiet unterrichtet wurde,
spricht er heute fünf Sprachen.
Ich bin der deutschen Sprache
erst spät begegnet: mit 18 Jahren.
Es war Liebe auf den ersten Blick.
Es ging mir so unter die Haut.
Ich war begeistert, beflügelt.
Aber dabei war entscheidend,
dass ich mich 6-8 Std. pro Tag
der deutschen Sprache widmen konnte.
Anders gesagt: Es kam niemand
nach 45 Min. und sagte,
ich müsste jetzt
diese Tätigkeit unterbrechen,
um mich einer anderen zu widmen.
Andre Stern musste sich nie
in eine grössere Gruppe einordnen.
Aber wie lernt ein Kind so,
sich zu behaupten,
mit Frustrationen umzugehen?
Willst du ein Kind, das kein Problem
mit Frustrationserscheinungen hat,
dann konfrontiere es
nicht mit Frustration,
sondern
mit möglichst viel Zufriedenheit.
Denn ein zufriedener Mensch
hat kein Problem damit,
mit Frustration zu leben.
Das ist Teil des Lebens.
Aber wenn dein ganzes Leben
eine Frustration ist ...
Die grosse Frustration
beginnt morgens:
Wir sind die einzige Spezies,
die ihre Kinder weckt.
Und dann ist dein ganzes Leben
ein Ozean von Nein.
Dann ist ein Nein mehr
manchmal eines zu viel.
Aber wenn dein Leben
aus lauter Ja besteht,
ist ein gelegentliches
oder gar regelmässiges,
aber nicht überwiegendes Nein
überhaupt kein Problem.
Stans im Kanton Nidwalden.
Hier absolviert
der Berner Till Grossrieder
eine Lehre als Polymechaniker.
Till ist kein Homeschooler,
er besuchte eine Schule
für selbstbestimmtes Lernen.
Dort gab es keinen Unterricht,
keine Prüfungen, keine Noten,
keine Bewertungen.
Warum wollten Sie Ihre Lehre
unbedingt bei Pilatus machen?
Flugzeuge
interessierten mich allgemein sehr,
seit ich zwölf oder 13 war.
Und dann war klar: Pilatus, Swiss
oder irgendeine Airline.
Pilatus gefiel mir,
weil man hier Flugzeuge bauen kann.
Den Zuschlag für die Lehrstelle
erhielt Till
nach einer Schnupperlehre
und dem betriebseigenen Aufnahmetest.
Doch diese Lehre
ist nur ein Etappenziel
auf dem Weg zu Tills Traum,
Pilot zu werden.
Bei der harten Selektion
für die Militärpilotenausbildung
ist Till ausgeschieden,
die bedingte Empfehlung als
Zivilpilot aber hat er auf sicher.
Es ist technisch, aber auch
menschlich enorm anspruchsvoll.
Ich finde das Zusammenspiel
der verschiedenen Elemente grandios.
Aber so hat es kein Spiel mehr.
Doch. Diese hier ist z.B. auch fest.
- Ah, ja.
Und doch hat sie etwas Spiel.
- Ach so.
Dasselbe
gilt für die hintere Schraube.
Der Übertritt von der Schule
für selbstbestimmtes Lernen
an die Berufsschule
verlief unproblematisch.
In den Fächern,
in denen alle bei null begannen -
Fertigungstechnik oder Werkstoff-
kunde - war es kein Problem.
Aber bei Mathe und Englisch
gab es Bereiche,
z.B. Algebra oder Grammatik,
in denen ich etwas nachholen musste.
Aber das waren vielleicht die ersten
drei Monate, und dann ging es.
In Algebra und Physik haben alle
bzw. die meisten Mühe zu Beginn.
Da merkte man, dass Till einsah,
dass er Schwächen hat, lernen muss
und darum Zeit investiert hat.
Und mittlerweile
ist er einer der Besten.
Er weiss,
wann er worauf fokussieren muss.
Er ist selbstkritischer, bereitet
sich besser, strukturierter vor,
um die Dinge zu lernen.
Er hat sein Zeitmanagement im Griff.
In der Schweiz wachsen heute etwa
700-1'000 Kinder unbeschult auf.
Tendenz steigend.
Ich hoffe,
dass es gesellschaftsfähiger wird.
Darum setze ich mich hier
auch gerne dafür ein.
Aber realistisch gesehen, weiss
ich nicht, wie schnell das geht.
Denn ich denke,
es braucht von den Eltern
recht viel Mut und Vertrauen
ins Kind, um das zu tun.
Andrea Liniger hat in Bern
den sog. Freilernraum gegründet.
Das erscheint mir gut so.
Hier treffen sich Homeschooler
aller Altersstufen,
um miteinander
und voneinander zu lernen,
in Workshops, auf Ausflügen,
im Spiel.
Ein Lerncoach
begleitet diejenigen Kinder,
die Unterstützung wünschen.
Ein voller Erfolg für Bastian:
Er hat die Aufnahmeprüfung an eine
Informatik-Mittelschule geschafft.
X ist gleich drei.
- Mhm.
Schön wäre, wenn Kinder
angstfrei lernen könnten.
Meine Idee ist nicht,
dass Schulen abgeschafft werden.
Sondern dass sich das System
in die Richtung ändert,
dass Kinder ihr eigenes Lernen
und ihre Bildung
vermehrt selber gestalten können.
Ich erzähle euch etwas
über die Atombombe,
wie sie funktioniert,
wie sie ungefähr aussieht.
Little Boy -
sie wurde über Hiroshima abgeworfen
und hat 160'000 Menschen getötet.
Sterben die Menschen sofort,
wenn die Atombombe einschlägt
oder dauert es eine Weile?
Der Freilernraum will keine Schule,
sondern eine Ergänzung
zum Lernen zu Hause sein.
Ein Ort, wo Kinder Lernen
mit positiven Emotionen verbinden.
Es gibt keine begabten
und unbegabten Menschen.
Das ist nicht genetisch.
Das weiss man inzwischen.
Es ist nur eine Sache der Emotion:
Ein Thema berührt uns oder nicht.
Wenn es uns nicht berührt, dann
können wir es einfach nicht lernen.
Die Information
geht da rein und da wieder raus.
Deshalb halten wir es für normal,
80 % des Gelernten
wieder zu verlernen.
Und die 20 %,
die wir nicht verlernen,
sind mit einer Emotion verbunden.
Es ist so: Es gibt niemanden,
der in Mathe nicht gut ist,
es gibt nur solche,
die ein Mathetrauma haben,
weil ihnen Mathe auf eine Weise und
zu einem Zeitpunkt auferlegt wurde,
in dem sie dafür kein Interesse
und keine Emotionen empfanden.
Das bleibt einem für immer:
Man schafft es nicht
und man bekommt gesagt,
man sei schlecht.
Der Franzose Andre Stern hat zwar
nie eine Schule von innen gesehen.
Trotzdem ist er kein Homeschooler,
sondern Freilerner.
Denn Stern war - anders als
die Schweizer Homeschooler im Film -
absolut frei
in der Wahl seiner Themen.
Für ihn gab es keine Lehrpläne,
keine Pflichtstoffe,
keinen Unterricht,
schon gar nicht von seinen Eltern.
Ich finde, wenn schon Unterricht,
dann besser nicht zu Hause.
Erstens, weil das Zuhause
nicht dafür gedacht ist.
Das Zuhause ist der sichere Hafen.
Denn dann
ist man zu Hause eingesperrt,
und das ist eine kleine Welt.
Und wir sind für diese kleine Welt
nicht gemacht.
Wir sind für die weite Welt
und für alle Altersstufen gemacht.
Aber besser als zu Hause
mit allen Ängsten seiner Eltern
eingesperrt zu bleiben -
denn die sind sehr einengend ...
Mein Sohn klettert gerne auf Bäume.
Ich kann das nicht sehen,
habe Angst.
Würde er nur mit mir zu Hause leben,
dürfte er nie auf Bäume klettern.
Er geht aber in die Welt hinaus
und verbindet sich mit Menschen,
die keine Angst davor haben.
Das ist die grosse Befreiung.
Wenn schon Unterricht, dann besser
doch mit anderen Kindern zusammen,
was ein Ghetto
und eigentlich sehr fragwürdig ist.
Aber es ist zumindest
weg von zu Hause.
Und deshalb ist für mich ...
... Heimunterricht ...
in meinen Augen ...
... die schlimmste Variante.
In Ihren Augen müsste man
also die Schulpflicht abschaffen.
Wenn man etwas abschaffen müsste,
dann die Schulpflicht.
Es lohnt sich, darüber nachzudenken.
Nicht die Schule abschaffen.
Dieses Gespräch führe ich
auch mit Menschen, die unterrichten.
Wir denken über vieles nach.
Z.B. auch darüber, wie schön
es wäre, Menschen zu unterrichten,
die freiwillig in die Schule kommen.
Lisa Müllers Kindheit
glich eher der einer Freilernerin,
denn einer Homeschoolerin.
Statt Vokabeln zu lernen,
machte sie lieber das Fischerpatent.
Mit 15 dann entschied sie sich,
die Matura zu machen.
Ich füllte ein Kreuzworträtsel aus
und merkte,
dass ich wahnsinnig wenig weiss,
dass ich keine Ahnung habe,
was da gefragt wird.
Ich wollte darum meine
Allgemeinbildung aufbessern.
Der eine Weg wäre gewesen,
das selber zu tun,
sich selber zu informieren,
endlos viele Bücher zu lesen
und doch nie richtig zu wissen,
was zur Allgemeinbildung gehört.
Mit dieser Frage
beschäftige ich mich noch heute.
Und dann kam der Weg der Matura:
"Die Matura
kann man auch noch machen,
damit kann man danach studieren."
Lisa trat ins Euregio-Gymnasium
in Romanshorn ein
und bestand nach drei Jahren
die schweizerische Matura.
Hallo, Lisa.
- Grüezi, Herr Lippenberger.
Wir haben uns länger nicht gesehen.
- Ja.
Sie waren zwar nicht am Alumni-
Treffen, aber jetzt sind Sie da.
Ja.
- Was machen Sie zurzeit?
Ich arbeite am Gallusmarkt
für das Studium.
Und studieren Sie auch schon?
- Nein, erst ab Herbst.
Was werden Sie studieren?
- Geografie.
Schön. Und wo?
- In Zürich.
Es gibt hier
auch noch Bilder von Ihnen.
Mal sehen,
ob Lisa da noch drauf ist.
Das ist ein jüngeres.
- Da bin ich nicht drauf.
Da sind Sie. Wunderbar. Und
natürlich Simone, sie war wichtig.
Ich genoss es eigentlich.
Ich fand es schön.
Man konnte sich hinsetzen
und jemand erzählte etwas.
Um einen ersten Eindruck zu erhal-
ten, braucht man nicht viel zu tun.
Das kannte ich nicht.
Das fand ich
je nach Lehrperson sehr schön.
Gewissen Lehrern
hörte ich sehr gerne zu,
weil es spannend, interessant war.
Lernen war für sie wie für andere
Menschen trinken oder essen.
Es war,
als stillte sie ein Grundbedürfnis.
Das spürte man bei ihr.
Und sie lebte es ohne Blockaden.
Es gab gewisse Probleme,
Reibereien mit Kollegen,
die diese Erfahrung nicht hatten.
Ich fand, es gab beinahe
so etwas wie Neid ihr gegenüber.
Weil sie diese Kraft und Offenheit
gegenüber den Themen hatte.
Also, gab es Probleme
mit Lehrer-Kollegen?
Nein, mit Schülern.
- Können Sie das umschreiben?
Man sagte sich: "Wir haben uns
jahrelang durch die Schulen gequält,
und jetzt kommt die da und rennt mit
ihrer Fröhlichkeit an uns vorbei."
Es war ähnlich
wie in einem Beamtenapparat:
"Ich habe so viele Jahre hinter mir,
du so viele,
also habe ich die höheren Rechte."
Das spürte man schon ein bisschen.
Italienisch hat mich total gepackt.
Ich mochte es sehr gerne.
Wir lasen "Dante" - ein recht
alter Stil des Italienischen,
fast noch lateinisch,
was ich extrem spannend fand.
Ich konnte mit der Lehrerin
stundenlang darüber reden,
es interessierte mich einfach.
Da merkte ich,
dass die Mitschüler genervt waren.
Sie fanden, das gehöre nicht
zum vorgeschriebenen Stoff.
Sie wollten nur das Minimum lernen.
Und wenn es tiefer ging, wollten sie
nicht mehr, nicht noch mehr Stoff.
Für mich war es eine Hilfe.
So hatte ich bis dahin auch gelernt:
Je mehr ich von etwas weiss,
je tiefer es geht,
desto leichter fällt es mir dann,
die oberflächlichen Sachen
bei der Prüfung
wieder herunterzuspulen.
Im Herbst beginnt Lisa ihr Studium.
Die Berufswelt wartet auf
Homeschooler und Freilerner wie Lisa,
davon ist der Rektor des Gymnasiums
überzeugt.
Sie braucht Leute, die sich nicht
nur auf gegebene Rezepte fixieren.
Die Welt ändert sich täglich.
Und mit den Neuheiten
muss man umgehen.
Das hat man
auch hier im Haus gemerkt:
Es gab Leute, die sich darüber
aufregten, dass für Lisa nichts ...
... nach dem Motto "Das haben wir
doch schon immer so gemacht" war.
Für Lisa war immer alles neu.
Und das ist auch eine Chance
in der Berufswelt.
Man ist nicht auf alte Rezepte,
Konzepte fixiert,
sondern sucht das Neue.
Dass man Neues auch aufnimmt
und es nicht als Bedrohung sieht.
Ein "normaler" Schüler denkt sich
immer: "Wie muss ich wem genügen?"
"Auch in meiner Art zu denken."
Und das machen die Homeschooler,
die ich erlebte, nicht.
Ich erlebe oft, dass die Leute
vor lauter Anpassung
gar keine Ziele mehr haben.
Sie wollen nur nicht auffallen.
Und irgendwo gibt es ein kleines
Kämmerchen, wo ich ich bin.
Aber das findet dann keiner mehr.
Ich denke, wenn man Zeit für sein
Leben hatte, weiss man, wer man ist.
Man hat einen Kompass in sich.
* Kirchenglocke *
Ich wuchs mit dem Gefühl auf,
richtig zu sein, so wie ich bin.
Und ich merke heute,
dass ich einen Boden habe.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
das rührt daher.
Ich weiss, egal, was ich mache,
ich habe eine Unterstützung,
die nicht auf einem Handeln beruht
oder darauf, dass ich etwas mache,
sondern es ist eine tiefe Über-
zeugung, dass ich meinen Weg gehe,
das Richtige tue oder das tue,
was für mich richtig ist.
Das finde ich
ein sehr schönes Gefühl:
zu wissen, dass es nicht darum geht,
was ich mache,
sondern wie ich es mache
und dass ich es gerne mache,
dass es mir gut geht,
dass ich meinen Weg finde.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmelodie *